tell me which one you prefer same guy
first category he's broke he'll always
be broke and he's a virgin the second
guy he is wealthy decent guy wealthy guy
he's been with 20 girls intimate
Partners in his past which one would you
pick
I've done the seven day free trial of
the qurani app and it exceeded All my
expectations alhamdulillah I was worried
that was an overrated product that's why
that's before until you tried it what
was the sister you can build a habit
with the Quran by seven day free trial
promises no credit card details required
at all and you decide for yourself is it
overrated or is it underrated imagine a
guy that you visually like who's
handsome and everything you're looking
for I'm gonna put him into two
categories tell me which one you prefer
same guy first category he's broke he'll
always be broke and he's a virgin the
second guy he is wealthy decent guy
wealthy guy he's been with 20 girls
intimate Partners in his past which one
would you pick which one would you go
for I would personally go for the one
that was broke before
start building your future together
slowly eventually and personally I think
that would be more of a right mindset
okay wife is going to stay broke forever
I'll probably get a job I don't
okay so you would be the provider yeah
so broke virgin 20 bodies millionaire
which one
and the psychology between men and women
yeah
why though it's got pain no because if
you're still gonna respect me why am I
why am I gonna go for the brick one
that's true though because I wouldn't
expect a man to judge on Maya on our
past like okay see that's very
interesting the reason I'm doing this
experiment is because men and women
think differently we judge a Girl by her
past you guys judge a man by his future
so you look at man and be like okay
where's he going to be in 5-10 years as
a man obviously it's exception to the
rule we judge a Girl by her past
so we're just trying to find the so
that's why I'm asking man ask a woman as
well he's broke and he's going to stay
broke for the rest of his life
and he's a virgin and then you've got
any next man who's a millionaire well
he's got 20 bodies
20 intimate partners
okay interesting why the broke one
yeah by the way he's like he's a bomb
he's not gonna he's gonna be brought for
the rest of his life you're gonna be
working
[Music]
you go for him like yeah
it's like he doesn't have aspirations
because why are you still wouldn't be
perfect so is it is it true if I say a
woman judges a man by his future yeah
and or the second option is a
millionaire but he's got 20 20 bodies
for a woman for you it doesn't matter
but foreign
Woman by the past and a woman judges a
man by his future that's the reason why
he picked the man with 20 bodies because
you care about his future we care about
a woman's past Yeah so basically he's
somebody who's just he's broke but he's
never had to pass and then you have
someone who's had 20 intimate Partners a
man but he's rich think both options are
off-putting but if I had to choose one
it'd just be the wealthy person because
I knew that they would provide for me
and that is what I want in life just a
provider I know that he's been intimate
with other people but that's just not
what I want and if I chose a broke guy
and he's like a virgin like he's just
not going to be rich at all he's not
gonna strive to be anything because he's
going to be broke for the rest of his
life if you're providing imagine you
come home and he doesn't do mine and
he's just sat on the couch and you're
just paying for everything
okay foreign
you've got a wealthy guy that's got 20
intimate partners no I I get what you're
trying to say now if I might honestly
consider the wealthy person because if
he is gonna repent and he you know has
looked down on himself this ain't the
life that I want to choose I'll
definitely give him a shot okay I don't
care about how many people he slept with
okay why the
am I correct to say that a woman judges
a man by his future and a man judges a
Woman by her past yeah
yes than a wealthy yeah yeah
it doesn't matter if it's yeah okay
why does the body is not matter to you I
don't think the body is people don't
really disclose it when you first start
dating them and so on so if you knew if
you knew you would go for the one that's
wealthy yeah I think
so just to clarify I'm not seeing that
we judge somebody but as men we give
importance to that now as girls you
don't so what happens is usually you
want us to think like you guys and we
want you to think about us but that's
why the conflict happens when we
understand each other's nature then it
just helps us to better understand each
other and get on with each other the
following statement true that a woman
judges a man by his future like
basically you are more concerned you
don't care about what he did in his past
you were more concerned about his future
so is it someone that's going to be
working is it going to be a provider as
a woman yeah currently as well like
present and the future is what is what
is important that's what I care about
yeah okay as a woman usually when a
woman at hypergamous by Nature so would
you not want somebody who if you are
providing for him are you not going to
lose interest it depends it depends if
I'm not getting treated well to be fair
okay if it's really well but he's just
you're you're the main Breadwinner
you're the provider I wouldn't
personally if you've been with multiple
girls
okay yeah okay so you basically you
would prefer to go for a broke guy who
has no past and somebody with uh how
about yourself
rather than somebody who's who's
wealthier yeah because I can I
as a woman you would want your man to be
the provider yeah yeah obviously yeah
yeah so
you do that citizens show that for
example you usually women tell me if I'm
wrong I'm having a discussion yeah
usually women are hypergamous by nature
which means that you look for a leader a
provider a protector so this is what's
up if you're if you're walking down the
road some guy comes trying to attack you
and he runs away would you find that
attractive
so that's what I'm saying due to
hypergamous Nature you wanted to be the
protector so when it comes to providing
yeah that's what I'm saying so from that
perspective but again you guys are
saying you prefer the pure guy broke
rather than somebody that's rich but
it's got past okay thank you that was it
so guys today we came to Shepherd's Bush
and we did a social experiment the
purpose of this social experiment was
not to demonize one gender or another
but to truly understand how a man and a
woman thinks and what they prioritize in
each other and how we are unique in our
own way and we have our own unique
things that we look for in the other
gender we would have a better future
that is the reason why we've done a
social experiment this is in no way
shape or form to demonize a brother with
a pass or a sister with a past or a
brother with his future or the sister
with his future but the aim is that we
understand each other and that's the
main thing inshallah and in Islam
alhamdulillah those who repent all their
synthetic event and it's a new beginning
but this is to just understand how a man
thinks and understand how a woman thinks
that was it hope you guys benefited from
it it's been called it's been freezing
but I really enjoyed it until next time
if you would like me to do more social
experiments like this different topics
come in the section below